I was gonna dress that intro really
takes all day and out of my brother but
I don't want to just sigh but anyway
welcome back to amnesia this one is
called Nexus it's quite the famous
custom story and they tell us to play in
the dark with headphones we just check
um I actually said I was gonna not
upload anything more today I don't know
if I'll upload this today but because I
was too tired and I am tired but I don't
know I felt like this is a perfect
timing person waking up out of the bed
wake up in the morning feeling like
hella pity I always share what are you
doing there
quite the color lovely mood here let's
read what this is all about the days
have been getting shorter and colder of
late and I think it is about time to
switch over to winter attire tomorrow I
should ask Joanna
that's sexy [ __ ] to have my bed refit
what oh and take a teach suit to Xena
I'm better lucky I find such a nice ass
place to stay
does my old home is in a labret burn
burn whoa oh is that
and this cousin stories a bit more well
me and Anna that's right word it's
probably meant a bit more serious and
what I usually played I should play them
but I wanted something firmly locked
just as my nothing I'm not even gonna
say it anymore but I wanted to play
something more serious and longer just
whoa
oh now ah this is not good for me or my
genitals they don't grow very fast
what sometimes I just wonder what the
hell just words coming out of my mouth
there's somebody there
Gollum are you hiding when you hear mom
I don't even know what I'm talking about
another family locked hey Jane the box
Oh what the hell oh no he burned to the
ground burn to the ground
okay alright okay I thought I found a
secret behind just burn yeah I didn't
even get a chance to talk to him
oh no what alright let's just keep going
s page
yes don't even needed a key I like a lot
of blue
alright see more adventures his Nexus
has to offer I don't even know what
nemesis means I think it means Chinese
bun cheeks but I'm not sure oh no mr.
shower man they were so many you have no
idea there were like 20 of them 25
minutes - what is that quick 20 wrong
what I'm gonna wise ask question I don't
what to show you so crazy
Holly [ __ ] time all right okay another
map it's not possible who flipped you
over mr. pot who flipped yeah someone
flip yeah are you know talking to me mr.
pot you should wear mister shares a
helmet there you go nice and fine like
my your mom's ass okay then I just come
from
oh oh I'm so silly silly pants everybody
oh all right
ah what they are doing that let me just
squeeze through oh oh you're lucky I'm
fat
you're like a [ __ ] what is this did you
kill this dog bone right if I'm not dead
what did you kill him I'm not gay
where's your dad don't be ridiculous all
right for all delicious feet find one of
each following a human arm a human leg a
human body this has been even passed
down through generations since the
establishing this chasm when it's
inhabited the reign of what celebrate
the military victory it's time to honor
its tradition this leg you're not dinner
it's obvious hell is going on here okay
sounds fair enough oh oh [ __ ] your chest
I just wanted to loot you I salute you
no that makes no sense
I thought we were on the same team chest
and we're not disappointed
you're not even oh oh oh that's it
that's it I'm putting you on the barrel
list uh-huh you can go and hang out with
the barrels in our chest no longer bro
all you lock the door didn't ya if you
you're smart huh you think you're smart
you think you don't think I can hook him
over here huh you think you're saver ah
rah rah I know you disorient me like
lady guy off the poster okay I didn't
even know oh look it it DS I found it
the torso I found you torture you will
never fight whatever did this you're
looking fine we will join the battles
and our barrels will drew a look no you
want no you want just
okay now we just need a human arm
mildest one simply find a human arm are
you a human arm no you're not but I saw
perhaps in the boxes I don't trust these
boxes anymore
hey there you are lovely hi penny
I'm on your side let me rub your NEFAs
why does everyone want to talk about
nickels okay
well let's see what it was again for the
delicious feet final minor then over
okay I just need to put them there
that's what I thought
don't do it ready I'm not with my I
don't care order oh come on it's closet
time it's gone oh no no no no no no no
no no no
to run hot what the hell is going on
here okay
what about Doris oh okay okay okay okay
Fernando is correct the pasado
ah si señor let's ona all right wake up
in the morning feeling like P Diddy
I'm so [ __ ] screwed I don't even know
which is the right door yesterday best
box all right Oh make that all on the
floor smack that give me some more smack
oh [ __ ] me oh I can't go down here
hey bro are you
what all right Bufo same [ __ ] night
I don't know Nana crap crap crap holy
sugar my life this color so is
terrifying I didn't think it would be
this itching
I just wanted no I don't want to get
naked tricks here
you were like oh he's gonna get naked I
like that no you don't own oh you're so
silly
this is not a porno you see Jennifer
what are you doing here Jennifer let me
love you tonight hey what am i I'm in
hell heaven the world beyond the
space-time lies behind the dithiol at
rabbit upon mine I totally nailed that
world bird whatever lon haha introduce
portal the portal to the heart of soul
of a very person Viva these flashier
exterior peel away to reveal all in
spruce spirit though the world itself
meets in track within are other forms
angry with also now together expensive
love in the closure I'll probably
enjoyed by truck waiting a cart along
there nail less they'll come on got away
done reading see the pants right your
pants bra get if I so desperate even in
hell heaven whatever it is
and translate great sweet stuff here
alright lemme dish go over here and say
hello to write sup John how you doing
the water Sharon's peaceful in pattern
that somewhere familiar and comforting
I bet it's this face of this garbage man
give me a kiss
jump kiss oh oh you kiss me down there
oh it's okay I get it
hey flash it's bash alright let's focus
we need to know what to do
and we know to know what should not do
it's a banishing Rock
I'm stating the obvious well done pity
I'm gonna do that very good at doing
that
what what someone hey why are you going
why are you going
whoa what is that what are you doing
stop following me
stop it's not funny hell are you doing
whoa no what are you doing son
don't follow me I swear to god I hate
one auto online corner like a bottle all
right the [ __ ] are you doing
get a life whoa are you going bro
oh it's coming after me I get it I get
it
come here come here come here
ah yes ha they're attracted sexual
silence that's why come here come here
ha ha ha
naylet once all connect happy sandwich
another consciousness the connection
grows and maintains itself then the core
of holes being it is from within the
core that interaction between these two
are being mediated it's not lovely
vagina did you hear that vagina did you
hear that
of course you didn't you don't know
anything okay oh is that computer how
are you telling me some whoa hey hey hey
Shh that I don't know what you're doing
I don't know what you like chocolate
perhaps I love chocolate it doesn't
laugh time I think I'm safe here or
something it's really weird
come here wait I dare you
cross the line [ __ ] yeah too easy
is it a puss or something yeah that's
possible isn't it Kelly come here fishy
what am I supposed to do here difficult'
no it's not really that difficult but
that's okay cuz they're streets and it's
kamek hey hey don't follow me
maybe oh I know what I need to do but
next episode alright so apparently I was
correct I just needed to it's something
change it's this inception mom rhyme ah
alright I made it lovely
I don't even know what I did but I did
something that's all that matters in
life
delicious nutritious back in the warm
leather dishes
I don't know Elsa I told you Anna to
tell you where I was
hopefully you shall seeing this soon
while I was waiting for you I decided to
begin lonely
searching through the chemistry books
here perhaps I should say even find the
book written by one of our law
professors but you know me I can't stand
waiting around you should find the
waiting walking bookshelf Victor quids
t-this one crazy guy that guy I know him
we used to do stuff together oh no oh no
that is going on kind of drug guy takers
oh ah come on uh alright uh uh uh which
way which way which way
Oh little lid off kick ground cough
cough Lana Big Brother all right hang on
generations
whoa all right oh I don't like no me
gusta
come on read me a bedtime story someone
are cockroaches everywhere and different
get away from my skin Oh dad is going on
here
alright alright no probably oh why am i
walking circles here how's this even
possible Lech me
and up me all right
hey yo where the hell is going because
the story is freakish Ruger Oh No
nah I'm finally into trans mode again
Aaron oh hey
techno music oh is it what damn oh look
at that guy
hey Matt Dean watch it
hey I got it
choking on dicks all right I think we
need to Janet yeah all right so like in
favor of you enjoyed subscribe to come
with rotating away old like okay why
would I
ah that little [ __ ] oh oh he's going
down and going back down
why would he shoot me